we'll start out at the very start so
we've got this word symposium and when
you hear the word symposium
comes to mind because it means something
very different today and they used it
back in the time that was writing so
yeah okay yeah that's that's that's at
the core of getting together the swim is
the sin you know that we have that's
what happens when you put in front of a
PE goes to usually if we talk about a
symposium or symposia what are people
getting together to do well that's what
they did in Plato's time drink but we
don't say I I'd like to have a symposium
would you stop by my place at six
o'clock and bring you know a six pack or
you know a bottle of wine you know we
don't say stuff like that usually if I
invite you to a symposium what am i
probably inviting - yeah their leaves
would be probably a panel up in front
you'll sit out there and chairs sort of
like these but they'll be more
comfortable
it'd be a nicer room and they'll talk
about something maybe it's about you
know whether we should go to war with
Syria you don't have like ten experts
maybe three or four experts and each of
them will give their their you know
their take on it and then maybe they'll
argue with each other and they'll feel
some questions from the audience there
won't be any drinking until the event
most likely some people might have
flasks that might actually help you get
through it some symposia so you might
wonder well that doesn't sound anything
like what's going on in Plato's sing how
did we end up with things where they are
today and you know some of them is the
long history of his terms symposium
Plato changed it in a way because
symposium originally means drinking part
the getting together and this this word
podium we get the word potable from that
put on the portable means drinkable like
potable water and it comes from the verb
to drink so this is a
for them to get together and drink wine
in some big cups they didn't have beer
yeah a few other things and you know
what else do people like to do with
their drinking did music you notice they
have to send away a flute girl who is
going to be playing during the thing
what else people like to do when they
think their experience yeah and they
have a big dinner beforehand you can
probably imagine they're still gonna
have snacks around you know in case
anybody gets hungry halfway through the
night and they're laying down on couches
the Greeks and the Romans also didn't
necessarily eat sitting they often they
often ate laying down it was more than
last kind of thing
they're sitting together on the couches
you know they're big enough that they
can share and they're just hanging out
and why aren't they going to do heavy
drinking in this this case
well that's putting a nice face on it
that's not the original origin of it
yeah exactly
they drank so hard at the celebration
the day before because this guy Agathon
whose house the symposium was being held
that he just won a major contests he is
a playwright to use a true tragedy
writer so you know maybe you read
Aeschylus or Sophocles or Euripides when
you were in high school maybe they'll
read them here those are Greek tragedies
Agathon is coming after those guys he's
younger than them and they had contests
every year for writing tragedies and
putting these tragedies on he wants well
so you're in a couple different engines
not all these guys are philosophers the
only one who is really a professional
philosophers Socrates yeah intellectuals
yeah that's a good way to put it these
are all people who are part of the Greek
the Athenian upper class they're their
leisured they're able to devote their
time to things like writing comedies or
in tragedies one of them's a doctor one
of them is a legal experts Alcibiades
bursts in at the end and he actually
comes a general later on now whether
what the weather they're drinking hard
to sort of validate what they're saying
no as a matter of fact once they
actually start drinking hard again the
party the intellectual stuff is over and
it just turns into a fun hangout
everything goes there there are some
guys at the end of the night still
arguing with each other the three last
men standing
Agathon Aristophanes and Socrates and
he's arguing with them about
their particular crafts can the same
person write comedy like Aristophanes
does and tragedy like Agathon does
because both of them are specialists and
the guy who I actually studied with his
suggestion with that is yes and Plato is
the person who actually does write both
of those in the symposium that's that's
a whole different issue so yeah to go
back to it they're they're really
hungover they drank harder they partied
the night before and they're just not up
to tells you how much these guys drink
they're now up to another night of heavy
drinking the thought does not does not
move them normally these guys would like
to do that and everybody there except
for Socrates tends to get drunk
Socrates can do whatever he wants and
he's not really affected like he's got a
weird kind of Constitution now they've
also got that doctor there and the
doctor does tell them you know it's not
really good for you to drink so much I
always counsel moderation so they say
okay we're not gonna drink what are we
gonna do that's why they start coming up
with this notion of giving speeches it's
not like they said hey let's get
together for the book club over here and
we're gonna talk about ideas originally
it starts up we're gonna we're gonna
celebrate we're gonna party and then if
we're not gonna drink well how should we
fill up the night well let's talk about
stuff and what should we talk about
then this suggestion comes up let's talk
about love why
what's what's so important about that I
mean people are interested in it right
but why do they end up talking because
nobody had done it before
nobody has given a speech and praise of
love people have praised all sorts of
other things even down to like talking
about different kinds of salted water
these are you know the Greeks are into
quicking so but nobody up until this
point has really told us why love is
such a great thing so that's an
interesting philosophical topic and then
it rolls on from there let me back up a
little bit though one of the things that
I want to call your attention to because
it shows you the craft work going into
this is what we call narrative function
now during the night we're going to get
speeches and there's really there's a
sequence of six so each person is going
to take up a block of time and talk
about love I also buy these is actually
going to talk about his love for
Socrates and what kind of a swell guy
Socrates is so he's a little bit off
topic but that's okay because he crashed
the party he wasn't there at the start
so we didn't hear all these other
speeches these other speeches kind of
build off of each other and that's the
core of the dialogue but is that where
the dialogue begins no starts out with
this guy Polydorus
talking with somebody else we don't even
know some unnamed companion he says yeah
I was just talking with Glaucon about
this so there's kind of a nesting
we've got Apollodorus and mauka by the
way koala can display toes brother
Malkin shows up in a couple dialogues
Plato never puts himself into a dialogue
the eye and the dialogue is always
somebody else usually Socrates in this
case it's Apollodorus and he's telling
the story and when did this they
actually take place many years before
this is the says that happens when we're
boys you know glop and you thought this
happened laughs we know this happened a
long time ago
and so we're did Apollodorus hear this
from hearing it ultimately from this guy
there's the Dimas who then told it to
another guy and that guy I told it to
Apollodorus and Apollodorus thought
things were kind of hazy so he checked
into socrates about this so this is sort
of like you hearing about something that
happened to your family before you were
born and then going around to your aunts
and uncles and grandparents and great
aunts and great uncles and asking did my
daddy actually say that because that
doesn't sound like him at all or you
know how did they meet again what's
what's the backstory on this sometimes
those things can be kind of surprising
camping and then even ever done that in
your family you know find out that
people had a very different life than
you you know come to associate them with
well Arista Dimas was actually there
now does IRISA Dimas do a lot of talking
not much he doesn't give a speech he's a
guy who likes to hang out with Socrates
all the time yeah and he meets up with
Socrates he's not actually invited to
the party although it turns out Agathon
didn't want to invite him didn't he he
just you know didn't know where he was
at the time
didn't have text messaging or you know
like that back then
so IRISA Dimas goes along Socrates
actually ends up lagging behind because
he does what Socrates typically does he
gets lost and thought it starts you know
trying to work out some sort of puzzle
and he stays back there then he finally
shows up about halfway through the
dinner and things don't get really
rolling until Socrates shows up then
they they have the you know should we
drink some should we not drink
yeah and they decide no we're not gonna
drink and now what we're gonna do
instead is give speeches papers will go
first
audience then it's supposed to be
somebody who doesn't go next
who's supposed to go next does anyone
remember it actually goes forth he's the
comedian
Aristophanes and so the doctor
Eric's witness this it was next and then
Agathon and then Socrates and then and
then after that point other people break
in they're all drunk
I mean Alcibiades was you know
stone-cold drunk himself he was
delivering his speech he's complaining
about it these other people burst in and
the the intention of or they're gonna
that kind of drink art and they're just
gonna talk about stuff like completely
goes out the window and everybody's
drinking and doing all sorts of stuff
and everybody's if it passed out at the
end of the night or over at that table
the last three guys were talking and you
could
you know probably slurring their words
it's you know the Sun has just come up
Socrates then gets up and goes about his
business not affected by the rest of the
people are probably the worse for wear
yeah okay so this is the basic structure
now there's something special going on
in Socrates speech this is something we
want to be attentive to as well how is
his speech different than everybody
else's because this is really where the
climax of the dialogue takes place thank
you this way so we have a story within a
story what happens when Socrates starts
talking after he gets done you know
going back and forth or bhagath on the
question and answer going from
Apollodorus and vulcan to that of his
party were you know dropping 20 years
going back in time what happens when
Socrates starts telling his stories he
goes back in time to doesn't at the time
of the parties taking place he's a
middle-aged man because he's an old man
when he dies how is he Sameer how is he
when he's telling a story about Yoda
he's a young guy like Phaedrus or
perhaps pontius Eriksson I guess is
probably the ventilation and the phone
is pretty young they also buy IDs are
young Socrates is saying you know back
when I was your age I knew this really
brilliant woman she taught me everything
about love here's what she actually had
to say to me so there's a story within a
story within a story that's the
narrative structure of this this entire
thing sort of mapped out now each one of
these characters represents a certain
kind of person a certain kind of
approach to the big questions about love
you're right they're all intellectuals
they're all people getting together and
they all have different perspectives
don't they
Phaedrus is a little bit hard to pin
down but he's a young guy his his
profession his characters not really
settle Poisson yes he's the law and
order guy he wants to talk about what's
you know right and wrong and what ought
to be the case and how to tell things
apart
Erickson because he's a practicing
doctor so he knows something about the
science of his time and he looks at
everything in a sort of scientific
medical point of view he uses the
terminology of ancient medicine post
audience uses the terminology of ancient
legal endeavors
Aristophanes is an actually existing
purpose these are all actual people but
Aristophanes is somebody who we know
about independently because he left
behind plays that if you want to you can
actually read Aristophanes was one of
the Kings of Comedy of his time he was
he was one of the people who represented
what they call the old comedy and the
old comedy was very raw stuff just to
give you an idea about how silly some of
this was on the stage the actors would
get on and they had these you know these
comedic masks so you couldn't actually
see their face but they also wore giant
phalluses that they could walk around
while they're talking to it to each
other that's kind of a funny image isn't
it imagine people now you know you're
reading a play you got a picture of
people actually talking to each other
this way because it was all about like
just you know goofy stuff and and they
would pick on as opposed to the the new
comedy which is more like sitcoms you
guys are all familiar with sitcoms you
know they started in 50s what are some
popular sitcoms today I supposed to
drama this or sometimes they call them a
situation nowadays you know they're not
sketch comedies where the characters are
different though the same characters
over and over again like one of the ones
I did I particularly like a particularly
volatile be sunny in philadelphia that's
a situation comedy the characters don't
develop they don't learn anything it
don't change become better people they
just do the the stupid things that they
tend to do and Max is a particular kind
of stupid dennis is a whole different
kind of stupid dee is a different caste
stupid they do their stupid things and
we laugh at it that's kind of shot
compared to old comedy old comedy would
actually target people you would say you
they actually had a part of the play
where the actors would step down from
the stage take the masks off and go out
into the audience
and yell at people harangue them
politicians other playwrights famous
people they would target people Socrates
himself is targeted in one of
Aristophanes plays called the clouds as
being this you know goofy tells
everybody everything they want to hear
kind of kind of snake oil salesman yeah
you had a question you know they're
gonna ask if he wrote the clouds because
he did yeah yeah and Plato references
that in this and a sort of hidden way
socrates mentions it at one point he
also mentions it later in another
dialogue called the apology Plato's is
imitating Aristophanes
he's putting him into the play and to
his own play and he has Aristophanes
tell the kind of stories that
Aristophanes likes to do you know this
big thing about well in the beginning
near these round you know four-legged
forearm creatures that also you know two
sets of reproductive parts and then we
messed with the gods and the guides you
know cut us right down the middle just
like you know cutting up an egg with a
hair this is one of those metaphors
because that's typical Aristophanes and
it's pretty funny when you when you look
at it Agathon is what would you think to
be the high point of the the dialogue I
mean we're here celebrating this guy's
triumph his is beating all the other
playwrights in this contest now a
tragedy was a big production you know
this is not comedy or just having you
know some laughs and a good time this is
supposed to elevate us this was supposed
to make us think about big things but
our own mortality about the nature of
fate and love and you know the right
life of the wrong life blindness and and
you know perceptiveness all these sorts
of you know big picture things and it
had to be in particularly elevated
language and the the tragedy writer was
sort of like not just a writer but also
a producer they had to oversee this
whole production so he's done that he's
going to give a speech that reflects the
kind of guy that he is and he's played
it as they actually here in the some of
the rhetorician some of the orders of
his time in Paris
gorgeous games Socrates gets up Socrates
says I can't give a speech you know I
thought it was up to it but then I hear
these guys and these are some real
talkers I'm not that kind of guy if you
want I can do the sort of thing that I
do every day you guys all know me I like
to ask people questions and we talk
about stuff I can do that but I can't do
this this you know giving a big worked
out articulate speech is that okay with
you and they say yeah that's that's fine
so what does he do now remember whose
party is this
daga thoughts right Angus I just gave
the best speech what does Socrates do
tears it apart
turns out a Agathon didn't know what he
was talking about that's kind of bad
manners isn't it but that that's typical
Socrates and Plato is not pulling any
punches with this and then inside to
tell us this this story about somebody
else somebody who's not at the party
somebody who's probably died a long time
ago the only actual woman philosopher
and the story is this person do to mom
who nobody knows you know whether she
truly existed or not or whether Plato
created her as a character but she
actually gets the the best lines doesn't
she she gets to tell you here's the real
story about everything else that these
guys was saying it's not completely
wrong but it's all pretty one-sided they
missed what it's really about
and so she tells that story this guy
Elsa by a tease I mentioned he
eventually becomes a general he is sort
of the typical golden boy
ancient Athens he's rich good-looking
strong bold everybody's in love with him
you know everybody wants to either you
know be him or sleep with him or be
friends with him very undisciplined
though he has no control over his
appetites in part because everybody
gives him what he wants yeah and he ends
up having a really tragic end much later
on he ends up betraying his city Athens
going to Sparta betraying Sparta in part
by sleeping with people he's not
supposed to sleep with going to Persia
which was the traditional enemy of the
Greeks so now he's like a double trader
and then while he's in Persia even
manages to betray that so you know this
is sort of foreshadowing in his
character and how he acts he tells you
when I'm around Socrates I want to be
the best guy that I possibly can but I'm
not able to sustain it
I'm not able to keep it up but he gives
you this really interesting speech about
who this guy Socrates is and what is so
attractive about this short fat
pug-nosed
you know balding old guy that all these
other people want to hang out with them
who by the way is not rich doesn't have
any political connections can't set you
up with anything
we'll drink you know all the wine that
you give them and it doesn't you know it
doesn't really care about too much when
it comes to physical things what's so
attractive about this guy that's what
we'll get to it yeah so there you have
sort of you know in a thumbnail all the
things that are going out of the speech
now well it's actually zero in this
guy's speech babies so faker starts out
and oh one thing - I did say I was going
to talk about this I'm gonna try to
cover this very quickly so these these
Greek guys are talking a lot about love
and you notice first off a lot of the
time they're talking about love between
men yeah they don't just mean like you
know being being buddies or brawlers
they mean that so you know some of the
actual sexual relationships and in some
cases this is kind of goes to that
question about photonic love Plato
doesn't go for that sort of thing but he
has characters who do in part because a
lot of the ancient Greeks did house
audience by the way of saying no you
shouldn't do that yeah early on in his
as well so there's the aspect they
didn't see any sort of inherent
contradiction between that and say
living a married life in part because it
was understood that if you were a member
of you know especially Athenian society
you needed to produce new citizens that
was your duty not only to you know say
your partner or your wife in the
marriage or to your family it was your
duty to the estate the society not least
because if you actually were a member of
the property class you were part of the
army the the survival of the city
depended on citizens being there and
reproducing in every generation so the
ancient Greeks didn't see a huge
conflict in many case
is between what we would call homosexual
relationships and heterosexual
relationships that mean they were all by
no I mean they have different
temperaments some of them talked about
being interested in men so I'm talking
about being interest into women
the biggest issue that they seem to be
concerned about is you know is the
person that they're trying to pursue or
sleep with the kind of person that they
ought to be pursuing so they're very
concerned about you know people sleeping
with each other's spouses that's a big
no-no and again in ancient societies
adultery was not just seen as a personal
effects it was seen as you know a state
defense you were actually undermining
society by doing that in ancient Athens
women were more or less confined to the
home with a few exceptions you noticed
eodum as a priestess right working-class
women of course had to work outside of
the home and slaves you know they had a
big slave Society of both male and
female slaves
none of this applied to them you've got
some working girls like the flute girl
but for the most part women were
confined to to the domestic sphere and
so what that meant was that if men were
going to have relationships in which
they would talk about things like
politics or Commerce it was going to
have to be with other men so you know
and we can we can worry about whether
this was you know wrong or unequal or
stuff like that I want to put those
questions aside to just focus on what
things are like so that we can
understand the text the other thing we
want to think about is this older
younger relationship the Greeks
depending on which her Greece you're in
and different attitudes about love
relationships romantic relationships and
even sexual relationships between men
and younger men or even boys yeah so you
see this talked about quite a bit in
there you notice that even in this this
symposium there's some very different
attitudes Express
right-ho Sonia says yeah people do that
sort of thing but you shouldn't be doing
that
and he's got kind of a strange
justification for it then we'll see did
you have a question or were you just oh
yeah
coz men marry each other in Aitkin
Greece or no they could look together as
companions if they want to do but no
marriage was understood as essentially
the relationship that you know binds
male and female together produces
progeny you could fall in love but that
wasn't necessarily expected as a matter
of fact you know you might not have that
much in common with a person that you
marry because a lot of marriages were in
fact arranged as relationships between
between houses
so Socrates had a wife who he put out it
he you know she may be very unfairly
portrayed by Plato
she's portrayed as being very nagging
and mean to him and he said that he
married her in part because if he could
put up with her he could put up with
anybody so there's not a lot of love in
that relationship I must love me in
something like enduring somebody else's
BS now on her part she put up with a lot
of stuff too you got this guy Socrates
who instead of actually working for a
living and taking you know what is his
parents have handed down to him
goes around town just getting in random
conversations with people about all
sorts of stuff and eventually gets
himself killed
Esther is all so it wasn't done rose
garden for her either so anyway this is
all stuff to keep in mind and we're
looking at these Greek conceptions of
luck I think it's very helpful if we try
to transpose a lot of this into
categories that were interested in and
more familiar with so I think that you
know we don't necessarily have to be
confined to thinking just of you know
older man younger man we can think of
this in terms of any struggles that you
where there's an older logger and a
younger lover you know we can ask
ourselves questions like well you know
what if somebody who's 14 falls in love
with somebody who's 30 you know could
that be a good relationship regardless
of sex whether they're both man both
women male/female you know older older
male older female these sort of things
can be can be generalized we're not
stuck necessarily with reading it just
with what Plato put on the table I find
that you know makes the text a bit more
more interesting well let's start with
this guy favors what's the first thing
he says about love great to be in love
it's wonderful
love is old a lot of us very very very
old and you might say well that's a
weird way to start why did why does he
care about that well you know for
ancient people and this still goes for a
lot of cultures antiquity is a sign of
greatness sign of being closer to the
origins of things we often we moderns
off intensity value of the old and say
the new the new is the best thing you
know so for example so much better than
my iPhone 3 you know this new iPhone 5
it is faster it could do a lot more
stuff when it comes to technology the
numeron probably is better but when it
comes to some other things because not
everything's technology maybe the older
really is that time is better the
ancient Greeks certainly thought that if
you're closer to the origin of things
that you're more powerful you're
greater dignity you matter you know we
we attitude sort of like that you don't
think about our monuments and museums
and the reverence in which the
Constitution is held you know which just
can't you know games a bit more people
disagreed about what it means but the
games a bit more every year doesn't have
this long you know ancient past to look
back upon and not a must remember of
course because we weren't alive even our
grandparents there's something to that
now he doesn't stop there
love is is very old but love is also
theories are getting to more substances
high is good love it is the best thing
of all why
I mean money's nice isn't it do you have
to decide lover money sometimes money is
the better thing to have
maybe not for your whole life but
certainly in some cases or if you're
really hungry food you know I'm really
really hungry I don't care if you love
me or not I want to eat and if you give
me a hamburger I'll be you know I'll be
your friend yeah we could run down a
whole list of other goods sometimes
sleep you know that doesn't last too
long you get the idea so what was the
place good how do probably know this to
be the case well here he makes a kind of
argument how do we know loves last good
what does love do for us that lets us
say this love lets us look at things in
a different
makes us consciousness over what does
favors things I think it makes us
conscious let's let's sort of sketch the
picture up you've all been infatuated
right now I can ask you how do you feel
when you're around that person I'll get
butterflies in my stomach I'm nervous
you know clumsy that sort of thing but
what are you really worried about it's
not like you know I'm gonna drop my cop
and then you know a little coffee will
spill I look like a doofus yeah yeah
we're concerned with Luverne or the love
depending on which side we run a
relationship if we're though if we're
the one that that is being logged by
somebody else then we feel like we have
to measure up to that in this case you
didn't think about like you know parents
and children but he actually says
parents you know that that sort of
dynamic is not as strong as the love
lover dynamic when somebody actually
loves us in romantic way we're sort of
on our toes we don't want to disappoint
them and what if we're infatuated with
somebody else but we really don't want
to disappoint them we want to appear to
be the best person that we are and this
leads to a lot of problems on dates
doesn't it you know when people have to
you know put on a different kind of face
than they normally have there's always
you know here's here's a common quandary
you take your date out to some
restaurant and maybe a show in town and
now you Castle almost personal now
you've got your own you know way of
dealing with homeless people already
this is
panhandling looking for change do you
give it to them well if you don't then
you look like you're kind of stingy and
especially you know you come up with
some sort of justification well you
don't understand spending on liquor
anyway or you know I gave to this guy
last week on the other hand if you give
in too easily maybe your lover you're
the person that you're interested in is
going to judge you as being kind of
sucker to is too soft too easy here this
quantity what should i do what should I
do and this can happen for a whole bunch
of things the the waiter you know brings
the stuff to the table and they're kind
of a jerk do you actively normally went
to them and maybe say something like hey
nice personality where'd you find it you
know or did you are you really gracious
with that because you want to appear
like you're a really nice person to the
person that we are you're attracted to
and you know this can lead you into a
lot of problems Canada because if you
add two differently from the person who
you really are now you've got this
appearance that you've got to keep up
all the time when you're with this
person and if the things work out you're
gonna be with this person the awful lot
of the time aren't you have any of you
ever seen that I mean we've seen this in
shows and movies and things like that
you guys have seen this with a life -
some of you probably experienced this
and then after a while the mass comes
down and then you know it can either be
like oh I can't believe you're that kind
of person see you later
or it can be I'm so glad you finally
felt like you could confide in me and
show me that you actually you know are a
slob or what else don't don't complete
your work on time
or get mean sometimes and tell people
OFF they can go a lot of different ways
but people are nervous about that people
are concerned about the opinion a lover
and so this this can actually bring out
the best of us can't it I mean is it a
bad thing if people who are normally
just average or even who you know let's
take the low way average when it comes
to moral things act like better people
because they don't want their their
lover to think badly of them what do you
think good thing or bad thing
yeah if you do something long enough
eventually it becomes part of who you
are
one way of thinking about this you put
on the mask and keep the mask on long
enough and pretty soon that'll become
your face because that's become the real
you maybe movies about that - no way
you know the ennobling effect this guy
over here usually it's more guys in
movies isn't it then then women although
it's starting to become a little bit
more even sometimes we have once or it
doesn't work out or not like bridesmaids
favorites favorite movies great movie
now he comes up with something really
interesting this proposal that probably
couldn't really work in any sort of
military even back in the ancient Greeks
time or in our time but it's an
interesting idea imagine an army or any
sort of military force composed entirely
of people who are in love with each
other and therefore are all trying to
look good in the eyes of their lovers
they would be unstoppable
compared to other sort of things that
motivate people like save money a lot of
people do fighting for money you know
fighting for money is not going to buy
you an awful lot of loyalty because at a
certain point you know things start to
get really tough somebody say well it's
great to have money but I don't want to
die good luck to risk you know going
into lightly death just just for the
money and even fear I mean you know you
can force people to go out and fight but
have a certain point they'll they'll
turn around should you instead
family connections you know pride honor
all these sorts of things but not as
powerful less you as a motivator faders
things as love as this foursome of love
and it's kind of an interesting idea to
think about you know could you actually
have something like this how would that
work
I mean when each person be in love with
each other person I suppose that'd be
the best way but now how would you pull
off something like yeah
come let's come up with some sort of
drugs everybody they're all on something
like a some weird mix of ecstasy and
maybe something else that makes you
aggressive because ecstasy tends to make
people just kind of touchy-feely I don't
know I I don't think that we have to
worry about whether this could actually
work because where is he going with this
love makes us willing to sacrifice even
our life somebody who truly loves is
willing to make what we call the
ultimate sacrifice and he brings up some
really interesting examples from Greek
mythology he brings up let's take the
one that who the failure personal
Morpheus
how many dinner herd of horses not
nothing that not you know from some
animate there he was musician such a
great musician that when he would play
stones would stop rolling down tail to
listen to him and all the animals would
come around
totally still and pay attention to what
he was so you're sort of like the first
rock star at this time yeah later on me
actually that's good rock star life
because after he loses his wife he's
just followed around by these women
music eventually tear him to pieces not
a good answer his wife dies Uranus and
he loves her but he loves life
a bit too much as well he goes down to
Hades to get her back and the story is
getting you know left out he doesn't go
by himself he takes Hercules with them
he has evolved heard of Hercules right
the ultimate strong man in Greece so he
takes Hercules down there to hell with
them and Hercules makes a big mess out
of everything and so it's fine you can
have her back but they pull a trick out
because he went down into hell alive he
didn't die to go they give them just a
facsimile a shadow and as she was going
up eventually he turns around and she's
like receding back in there he those who
are not willing to sacrifice everything
for love aren't worthy of getting their
love back when their love has died
now elke Estes is a whole different ball
game and all justice is a woman whose
husband that may just is told and I
don't remember the whole backstory on
this he's told you're gonna die here's a
curse
you're gonna die unless you can get
somebody else to take your place now
imagine you were in that sort of
situations the first people he goes to
her his parents they says look I'm gonna
die unless one of you is willing to die
for me mom dad what do you think they're
like yeah he's like you know you're old
already I'm I'm in the prime of my life
and you know I am your kid can't you
find somebody else can't you ask someone
maybe it's even worse off that that's
because we only have a little bit of
life left where we want to have that
life so now he's you know really on
quandary and his wife steps up and she
says I'll do this you're gonna have to
take care of the kids and maybe we
should talk a little in the play maybe
we should talk a little bit about what
you're going to whether you get marry
again after me but I'll do it and
Euripides play about this and it's quite
good things don't turn out well in every
given great tragedies but she's honored
and why because she is willing to make
the ultimate sacrifice for the sake of
her love that shows how strong a
motivation love this
the third example that he has is
Achilles
how many of you seen the movie Troy
maybe not too many I mean it's better to
read The Iliad than just to watch the
movie but it's not a bad movie and in
the Iliad Achilles is in love with
petroglyphs and petrópolis is actually
older than Achilles now Achilles is the
best warrior that the Greeks have and
they have like a whole stable of great
warriors Ajax Odysseus Agamemnon himself
is no slouch tell them on and they're
fighting against these Trojans and the
way they fight as a girl they stab each
other with you know Spears or swords or
things like this was very brutal and
Achilles is ticked off at Agamemnon
because the Agamemnon took this was
woman that we eat out as a captive I
think her name is Bruce takes her back
if you kill he's like I'm not fighting
for you Agamemnon is the commander in
chief so what you know what happens well
their best guy is out it's just like
when you're you know if you have a
sports team the first string quarterback
isn't there or the best linebacker isn't
playing what happens things don't go
that well right the Greeks are getting
trounced so if the Tropico stakes
Achilles armor puts it on well I'll go
out there
you know I'll go out there don't look
like Achilles put in you know an
appearance and what happens he goes out
there he's got some water Hector Kelson
Hector is the great warrior on the
Trojan side so Achilles finds us out and
Achilles this shows you how much he
loved petroglyphs he goes out and kills
Hector I many mutilates Hector's body
that is his dad actually has to come and
beg for him to let it go because
Achilles is so so angry now
so actually in some ways it's not the
best story but what his papers getting
at Achilles Achilles could have lived
forever he was half God not his mother's
side so if he didn't go out and avenge
Petropolis or do other crazy things
along those lines he could live forever
so he chose to give up his potential
immortality for her death yeah and he
did this why is he being so honored she
is the more beautiful one he is the
braver one
he's the stronger one he's the one who
should be loved more instead he is
willing to show love in battle in
Valerie interesting kind of kind of
ideas you know something to think about
these are very ancient and kind of
dramatic examples what would be examples
from our own time you go and try to
rescue the person who's drowning even
though it might result in you dying if
you love them what do you even think
about it what do you have to think about
it now if you truly love them right or
what if they need a kidney
it's not going to necessarily kill you
but it sure makes life tougher to only
have one of them do you provide it to
them if you love them again do you need
to think about it these are the sort of
examples I think we can relate to do you
put yourself in place of the the other
who's gotten themselves into a sticky
situation that's probably going to be
painful and take their place because you
you love them those are the sort of
things Phaedrus is talking about let's
look briefly now at puffs on mrs. house
audience is going to say that's nice
favors but remember when I ask you a
little bit earlier does love always
bring out the best in us what would you
say what are some ways that you've seen
in real life that love does not
necessarily bring out the best of us
when people like murder their ex-lovers
or something like that
jealousy oh yeah stalkers right and
jealousy itself even if you're in a
relationship he doesn't talk much about
this but the jealousy is a big problem
isn't it
what else
sometimes we don't always mean the same
thing by love doing don't people
sometimes say I love you to try to get
something out of other people I mean
they may feel like they kind of love
them at the time
what do they really want yeah I want to
get they want to get late they want to -
you know get sometimes you know any any
warm body will work right so I love good
there's that old old song you can't be
with the one you love love the one
you're with some people that's what it
means
and so how Sonia says there is good luck
and then there's bad luck she ties us in
with a whole story about Aphrodite and
whether after that is heavenly or
earthly so there there were actually
several different origin stories for
Aphrodite in one she's produced through
sexual reproduction
you know gods get together and they
arrive kids a lot of the gods came about
that way in another she comes from who
knows the the primal sky God one of the
guys who's there at the very beginning
who were announced and gay earth and a
whole bunch of kids those are the Titans
and Kronos is the one who becomes the
king of the gods by who else was a bad
guy he was very you know crazy he'll do
anything he's like super barbaric and
Kronos to actually cast rates up and
because that's one way to make sure that
you know he's not going to mess with
anybody anymore and she or he throws his
stuff into the ocean and Aphrodite comes
out of the waves
that's what Aphrodite comes from when
Sonic's is saying from heaven born
that's that's what she actually that's
what he actually hints about her so
you've got this contrast and he ties it
in with like this one being entirely
and this one is sort of indiscriminately
male and female what is he after in that
the real difference between these has to
do with this being about the soul and
this being about the body so the soul or
the intellect and this this brings up
that issue of platonic love coming up
earlier what is it that we want from the
body first we you know we see physical
beauty and we're attracted and then what
we want is sexual satisfaction see a
beautiful body we want to sleep with it
yeah that's a body body body beauty
service yeah my writing is getting worse
and worse as I get older to probably
look at it might be some neurological
thing anyway in any case there's a
difference between the body and the soul
and if the notion of the soul turns you
know think about personality you know
that which is within and only comes out
how do you see a person's personality
through their reactions through their
words through their attitudes bodies
really easy to see the body can be made
beautiful pretty pretty easily to Kanton
makeup you know it's one way of doing
that clothing you know clothing that
actually fits well makes a big
difference
working out exercise all those sorts of
things beautify the body what if you
want to beautify your soul that's hard
to do isn't it it's a bit tougher to
change your if your personality and some
people have good personalities and other
people you know frankly I mean you know
this to be the case some people don't
have good personalities right you
wouldn't want to be with them
relationship long-term they might be
nice to look at but you know they're not
they're not honest or generous or you
know they're they're actually cowardly
various vices so puffs Sonia says we
need to distinguish between these two a
lot of times when love comes into
disrepute he says when people look at it
I say love is a bad thing they're
thinking about this and this isn't even
a nearly bad it's just sort of random
because the body is is something
superficial and it can change very
quickly and people who are just into
things for this they're not looking at
the you know the bigger picture the more
important phenomenon the core of the
person people who are interested in this
they're more likely to have
relationships that are going to last for
a very long time and notice too with
this sort of relationship this is the
platonic relationship it's not about sex
it's not about getting off it's not
about satisfying a desire it's about a
developing intimacy with the person I
need to dance well can't you have both
would that be nice
and pulse Onix listen simple how if they
have both which you know it's kind of a
sad thing but then that's where he is
with that what else does he tell us
about about this
he tells us that there ought to be a war
there ought to be a law in Athens that
rules out acting on this sort of thing
with young boys now we could think about
this in terms of young people in general
why and you know in our time we would
usually say stuff like well they're a
young person they can't give consent
right or you know there's something
perverse about the older person wanting
to be with you know people who are quite
young maybe not fully developed there's
something a little bit off about
something skeevy he says well that's all
fine and good but really the big problem
is until somebody starts to develop
their soul and their soul shows you got
no idea what kind of person there
somebody might be quite attractive at 12
but you know you have no idea whether
they're gonna be a good person or a bad
person so it's better not to you know
have that sort of affection directed at
them at all you know somebody like y'all
somebody's it'd be a good case in point
maybe else by these would have been a
better guy if he hadn't been so
good-looking
if people that you know not said such
nice things to have given him gifts when
he was when he was younger yeah he says
some a few other things says what kind
of people are likely to ignore this well
people who are motivated by this kind of
love they're just looking for a warm
body that happens to look nice fits
their
aesthetic they're their type
they don't care whether the person is a
good person and it's probably not going
to be that lasting of a relationship
because once they actually get what they
want now suddenly you know they've got a
meeting the next day all these sort of
excuses that you see in movies right now
he also talks about Greek city-states
and it's funny because it's sort of like
a Goldilocks thing you know too hot to
cold just right Athens is just right in
some parts of Greece the rural parts all
they know is this sort of thing because
they're not very bright and the lovers
are allowed to do anything that they
like and basically it sounds like you
know rape is allowed which which is not
a good thing right in Persia in places
that are under the Parisian yoke they're
at the other extreme they rule that sort
of thing out Persians by the way were
for the most part monotheists and
probably had a lot more in common
religiously
with Judaism than they did with the
ancient Greeks which might be one reason
why you know this sort of thing was
coming up in any case the Greeks saw it
as the Persians just didn't like freedom
and if you can keep people from forming
attachments they'll be okay with tyranny
in Athens we've got this weird
hodgepodge of things yeah on the one
hand it looks like it's okay to be
having you know older younger
relationships on the other hand it looks
like it's it's not why well you know we
let lovers get away with all sorts of
stuff and nothing about our own society
if somebody can plead being in love
don't we sometimes excuse asinine
behavior that they engage in so this is
something you know that cuts across
cultures on the other hand this is
something also quite interesting think
about very permissive behave
and now think about whether if you were
a parent you would want your kid think
stuff and stuff like that like there's
great interviews with people who are
making porn for example and you know ask
them so would you let your daughter be
in one of your flicks they're like god
no and then you're like what I think
you're all about freedom and everything
goes and it's all a ok nobody's getting
hurt well yeah this is my my kid so
there's conflicting attitudes right
there's there's some sort of ambiguity
there well science has an answer for
that he says look if you can stick with
this sort of thing let it say okay the
younger person can be involved with an
older person in this sort of
relationship it's not going to be sexual
it's going to be one more like a
mentoring relationship the younger
person is hoping to learn something in
the process to become a better person to
acquire virtue and wisdom if it's this
sort of thing then we should actually
rule that out we should we should not
allow that to take place between mature
people and immature people because it's
probably going to be bad for them well
bad for both of them and that's why we
have this weird ambivalence in Athenian
law and we have someone almost sort of
ambivalences like that in our own
society when we start thinking about
should older people be involved in
romantic relationships with much younger
people when it's an issue of maturity
you know it's very different to say
should a 30 year old be involved with a
14 year old and should a 40 year old be
involved with the 25 year old in the
second case hopefully they're both
mature right more willing to say yeah
that kids understand that the 30 year
old in the 14 year old maybe there
really is a an issue there unless it's
going to be something that's not sexual
that's not and it's not like well we're
not gonna have sex right now but you
know you turn 18 because that would
still be this if it's this sort of thing
this can develop and today a lifelong
friendship